قدامنا هو مخيم جب الفلسطيني اكبر مخيم
لاجئين من حيث المساحه في المخيمات
الثمانيه الموجوده في غزه ورغم ان بقول
لكم الاكبر لكن مساحته صغيره جدا مقارنه
بالحي لاي حد من حضراتكم ساكن فيه مثلا
مساحته 1.4 م مربع بس تقريبا ربع مساحه حي
عين شمس في القاهره مثلا ومع ذلك كان ساكن
فيه 116000 لاجئ فلسطيني انا هخدكم دلوقتي
لشارع سوق جباليه اهم شوارع المخيم
واكثرها ازدحاما في يوم 9 اكتوبر اللي فات
بعد يومين بس من عمليه طوفان الاقصى اللي
شنتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه على مستوطنات
غلاف غزه التابعه للكيان المحتل في اليوم
ده وبدءا من الساعه 10 ال ربع صباحا بدات
طيارات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقصف
اهداف متنوعه في كل انحاء القطاع وفي نفس
اللحظات كان شارع سوق جباليا مليان بالاف
الفلسطينيين سواء سكان المخيم او النازحين
اللي بداوا يسيبوا بيوتهم بسرعه بناء على
توارد الاخبار ان جيش الاحتلال هث في
القصف على شمال القطاع بعد 45 دقيقه
بالضبط يعني الساعه 10:30 ضربت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه كذا بنايه في الشارع في غاره
عنيفه جدا قتلت ما لا يقل عن 69 فلسطيني
منهم اطفال ونساء وصفتها منظمه العفو
الدوليه في تحقيق مطول ليها بانها جريمه
حرب على الناحيه الثانيه هنلاقي جيش
الاحتلال قال ان الغاره استهدفت مجموعه من
اعضاء حماس كانوا متجمعين في مسجد هناك
كان ده مبرر يعني لكن عندنا مشكله جوهريه
بجانب التصريح الدموي ده انه ما فيش مسجد
اساسا في مكان القصف ده مش كلامي ده
الكلام الرسمي لمنظمه العفو الدوليه اللي
حللت صور اقمار صناعيه للشارع المجاور
للسوق وما لقتش فيه اي اثار لمسجد طب ايه
شكل القصف اللي حصل زياد حمد والد الشاب
عماد حمد اللي عنده 19 سنه واللي استشهد
في القصف بيوصف اللي حصل وقتها بيقول ان
الجس كانت محروقه ومتفهم لدرجه ان ما
قدرتش اتعرف على ابني وكله كان بيدور على
اطفاله في اكوام الجسس المحروقه منظمه
العفو الدوليه وصفت اللي حصل وقتها
بالمشاهد الجهنميه او مشاهد من الجحيم وده
ينفع جدا نخليه العنوان العريض لقذف
الاحتلال الجنوني على غزه والمستمر من 82
يوم لحد اللحظه دي قصف غير مسبوق في اي
حرب في اي مكان في العالم في ال 20 سنه
اللي فاتوا على الاقل استخدم في جيش
الاحتلال لحد وقت تصوير الحلقه اكت من
29000 قنبله مصها تقريبا غير موجه وغير
دقيق وعدد منها بيزن ما بين 500 كيلو لوا
طن متفجرات وقتل من خلاله اكثر من 21000
فلسطيني واصاب اكثر من
55000 ودمر حوالي 40,000 مبنى ومنشاه
وتسبب في نزوح حوالي 2 مليون شخص لمساحه
صغيره جدا جدا في جنوب القطاع مع نقص حاد
في الغذاء والمياه والادويه والوقود
ومستلزمات الحياه الاساسيه عموما في
عائلات فلسطينيه كامله يا اخوانا بكل
فروعها اتمسحت كانها لم تكن مئات العائلات
والاف الاسر ومئات الاحياء في القطاع اتسو
بالارض تماما طبعا بفكركم ان التدمير
الوحش ده كله في قطاع صغير لو ركدت عربيتك
هتاخده من الشمال للجنوب في نص ساعه بس
المجازر غير المسبوق بوقه دي بتتم بشكل
متعمد وبينفع الاحتلال عن طريق منظومه
عسكريه تقنيه كامله بتعتمد على قوائم
مراقبه واغتيالات فيها اكثر من 40,000 شخص
منظومه باهظه الثمن وصفها رئيس الاركان
السابق افيف كوخافي كانها طالعه من فيلم
ذا ماتركس المنظومه دي جيش الاحتلال
بيكونه بقى له 10 سنين وطورها في اخر اربع
سنين لحد ما خلاها شبه افلام الخيال العلم
فعلا بكل تقدمها وبكل قسوتها في الحلقه دي
هنفهم مع بعض ازاي جيش الاحتلال بيقتل
المدنيين الفلسطينيين بالكثافه والبشعه دي
وايه التقنيات اللي بيعتمد عليها علشان
يفضل مصنع الاغتيالات الجماعي بتاعه شغال
يعني ايه هو الماتركس الاسرائيلي ده وايه
هي مديريه الاستهداف اللي اتصرف عليها
ملايين الدولارات والمسؤول عن بحر الدماء
الفلسطينيه ومين اللي شغال فيها حلقه مهمه
جدا جدا لازم تشاركوها مع اصحابكم العرب
والاجانب بفكركم تتفاعلوا معاها علشان
تتجاوز قيود منصات التواصل الاجتماعي على
المحتوى المؤيد لفلسطين انا اشرف ابراهيم
ده المخبل
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا انا وفريق المخبر
الاقتصادي هنكون حابين نشكر جدا شركه تلا
فيت راعي حلقتنا النهارده شركه تلا فيت
اتاسس سنه 2017 وهي شركه فيتناميه اسسها
شاب مصري مكافح اسمه ضياء الدين امين
وبتصدر لاسواق مصر والسعوديه والاردن
وتركيا وغيرها منتجات مختلفه زي البن
والفلفل وجوز الهند والقرفه والكاجو
هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه تلفيت
علشان لو انت مستورد وحابب تتعامل معاهم
وتستورد من خلالهم المنتجات
[موسيقى]
دي
في عصر يوم 10 اكتوبر ضرب طائرات الكيان
الدموي مبنى مكون من ست ادوار في حي الشيخ
رضوان جنب مخيم جبلي على طول الغرا دي دكت
المبنى بالكامل وسوته بالارض وقتلت ما لا
يقل عن 40 مدني نصهم تقريبا من عيله واحده
هي عيله نفار طب ايه اللي خلى دوله
الاحتلال طقص في المبنى ده انها عندها ملف
حاطه فيه المبنى كهدف ضمن ملف الاهداف
الشامل لان في عضو من حماس ساكن في المبنى
في وقت القصف العضو ده ما كانش موجود
وماحدش برده عارف ان كان عضو سياسي في
الحركه ولا عسكري ولا منتمي لها بس بدون
اي نشاط حقيقي طبعا ما فيش حاجه في العالم
تبرر قصف مبنى كامل واباده معظم من فيه
سواء كان الشخص ده مدني ولا عسكري لدرجه
ان في مصدر عسكري اسرائيلي قال في تصريح
لمجله بلس 972 وموقع لوكال كل العبري في
تحقيقهم الشهير مصنع على الاغتيالات
الجماعيه انها ممارسات غير مقبوله وانه
حاول يتخيل اللي بيحصل بس بالعكس يعني لو
حماس عندها القدره مثلا وقررت تقصف كل
بيوت الجنود الاسرائيليين وعائلاتهم فيها
هيكون رد فعلهم في دوله الاحتلال ايه او
زي ما بتقول منظمه العفو الدوليه ان
العضويه في جماعه سياسيه ما بتخليش اي شخص
هدف عسكري وعضويته دي مش هتحول اي مبنى او
مكان هو فيه لهدف عسكري برده لكن
الاسرائيليين عندهم عقيده عسكريه وامنيه
لها قصه ثانيه عقيده مختلفه متطوره
تكنولوجيا ودمويه جدا القصه بتبدا في
يوليو سنه 2002 لما جت للاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه معلومه بمكان وجود صلاح شحاده
قائد كتائب عز الدين القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس ومؤسس اول جهاز عسكري
للحركه وبعد نقاشات سريعه خد الاحتلال
قرار باغتياله وقصفت القوات الجويه
الاسرائيليه المبنى اللي كان فيه في حي
الدرج في غزه وقتلته هو وزوجته وبنته و1
ثانيين منهم 11 طفل عمليه الاغتيال دي
عملت ضجه كبيره في العالم وفي الداخل
الاسرائيلي نفسه لان الاحتلال استخدم
قنبله وزنها طن كامل زي بعض القنابل اللي
بتضرب على غزه حاليه والعالم اتهم اسرائيل
في الوقت ده وعلى عكس المعتاد عالميا
بارتكاب جريمه حرب وساعتها مجتمع الاحتلال
نفسه كان في جزء مش متقبل ابدا استخدام
قنابل بالحجم ده بتتسبب في قتل عدد كبير
من المدنيين لدرجه انه ما بين 2002 و2003
عشرات الطيارين الاسرائيليين احتجوا على
استخدام القنابل الضخمه في الاغتيالات
والضجه والانتقادات الواسعه دي خلت
الاسرائيليين بعدها وفي محاولتهم لاغتيال
عدد من قضه حماس وعلى راسهم محمد الضيف
يكتفوا بقنبله وزنها ربع طن مقارنه بالس
سابق وده كان من اهم اسباب فشل الهجوم ده
لكن بالتدريج بدا مجتمع الاحتلال يتطرف
اكتر بكتير ومعاه جيشه نفسه وفي بدايه حرب
2008 على غزه خرج الجنرال الاسرائيلي غادي
ايزنكوت قائد المنطقه الشماليه وقتها
والوزير بحكومه الحرب الحاليه وقال اننا
هنستخدم قوه ساحقه ضد كل مكان بيتم اطلاق
النار منه على اسرائيل وهنس ابب للاماكن
دي اضرار ودمار هائلين وقال برض ان ده مش
كلام وانما خطه واقعيه تم اقرارها من
القيادتين العسكريه والسياسيه والهدف من
السياسه دي بجانب الردع الوحشي هو اجبار
السكان المدنيين على الضغط شعبيا على
المقاومه او اي جماعه بتقوم ضد الاحتلال
عموما العقيده دي عرفها العالم بعد كده
بعقيده الضحيه والامم المتحده قالت بعد
عدوان 2008 2009 على غزه ان الحمله
الاسرائيليه كانت هجوم غير متكافئ متعمد
بهدف معاقبه واذلال ارهاب السكان المدنيين
وتقليل قدرتهم الاقتصاديه المحليه بشكل
جذري على العمل واعالي نفسهم وارغام على
شعور متزايد بالتبعيه والضعف بسرعه هنلاقي
ان عقيده الضحيه تحولت لعقيده جيش
الاحتلال المفضله في التعامل مع غزه
تحديدا علشان كده في 2014 خلال معركه
العصف الماكول كان قصف منازل العائلات
الفلسطينيه المدنيه سياسه تقليديه وروتين
جدا لقوات الاحتلال وهنلاقي تقرير الام
المتحده في
2015 عرف اللي حصل في العدوان ده بانه
جريمه حرب محتمله وقال برض انه نمط جديد
من الاعمال العسكريه ادى لوفاه عائلات
باكملها النمط ده تحول بمرور الوقت لشيء
ثابت وبيز وحشيه وشراسه في كل عدوان يعني
مثلا زي ما احنا شايفين لو قارنا متوسط
الاهداف اللي الكيان المحتل ضربها في قطاع
غزه في حروبه الاربعه السابقه من اول
معركه 2008 ولحد معركه 2021 وقارنها
بمتوسط عدد الاهداف اليومي في معركه طوفان
الاقصى الحاليه واللي بقى لها 82 يوم لحد
لحظه تصوير الحلقه هنلاقي ارتفاع مهول
باكثر من الضعف في عدد الاهداف اللي تم
ضربها خلال العدوان الحالي وبالتالي حجم
الوفيات والمصابين والدمار اللي حصل طبعا
ده عدد اهداف مذه وعدد الاهداف ده ما كانش
ممكن يتحقق من غير المسار اللي مشي عليه
جيش الاحتلال لامتلاك منظومه ذكاء اصطناعي
قادره على تحقيق ده مع بدايه ثوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي واللي بدات تحديدا في اخر 10
سنين في الجيوش العالميه الكبرى وبيتصرف
عليها من ساعتها مليارات الدولارات كان
جيش الاحتلال من الجيوش السباقه في
استخدام الاي اي وانشا حاجه اسمها مركز
علوم البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي وده مركز
بديره الوحده 8200 اللي هي فخر وحدات
استخبارات جيش الاحتلال واكبر وحدات شعبه
المخابرات العسكريه امان مركز علوم
البيانات ده هو اللي طور نظام غير مفهوم
تحديد الاهداف في جيش الاحتلال كله وقلبه
من فوق لتحت وخلاهم بدل ما بيستغرق ساعات
علشان يحددوا هدف او مجموعه اهداف فهم
حاليا بيعملوا ده في دقائق معدوده وهو
النظام اللي شايفين نتائجه الدمويه قدام
عينينا حاليا علشان نفهم اللي بيحصل لازم
نفهم الاول حجم البيانات اللي بيتعامل
معاها الاحتلال علشان يولد اهدافه في
اوقات الحروب او الهدوء النسبي اللي بيحصل
انه يوميا ومع التطور الرهيب في وسائل
الرصد والمراقبه في كميات مهوله من
المعلومات والبيانات بتيجي لمجتمع
الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي عن طريق لقطات
الطائرات بدون طيار والاف الساعات من
تسجيلات كاميرات انظمه المراقبه في كل شبر
من الاراضي المحتله وصور الاقمار الصناعيه
والاتصالات بكل انواعها والمصادر المفتوحه
وغيرها من مصادر البيانات وحتى بيانات
اجهزه الاستشعار اللي تحت الارض عمليه جمع
وفرز كل البيانات دي كانت بتتم عن طريق
دمج العامل البشري بالتكنولوجيا يعني
الالات تفرز بشكل اولي كميه البيانات
المهوله دي وبعدها بيتعامل ضباط ومحللي
الاستخبارات بكل افرعها مع خلاصه
المعلومات اللي طلعت وبيبدا يصنفوا
اهدافهم واولو هم العمليات في ساعات او
ايام وهكذا لكن انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
الاسرائيليه حاليا بتعمل اللي كان بيعمله
مجموعه من ضباط الشباك او استخبارات جيش
الاحتلال المحنكين زمان وده كلام تال م
امران المحاضر في الجامعه العبريه في
القدس واللي اشتغل لصالح الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في مجال الاستهداف خلال
عمليات عسكريه سابقه واللي بيضيف ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي اكثر فعاليه بكتير يعني
مجموعه مكونه من 20 ضابط ممكن تطلع ما بين
50 ل 100 هدف خلال 300 يوم بينما شبكه
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن تقترح حوالي
200 هدف في غضون من 10 ل 12 يوم وده بحسب
بروفيسور تال معدل اسرع ب 50 مره على
الاقل سام ايفانس الباحث بالمعهد الملكي
للخدمات المتحده روسي واللي هو اقدم مركز
بحثي مختص بالامن والقضايا العسكريه في
العالم قال للاناضول ان شبكه تحليل
البيانات وتحديد الاهداف الاسرائيليه دي
بتعتمد على عدد من انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
اهمهم اربعه هم كالتالي بالترتيب الانجيل
ومصنع النار والكيميائي وحاق النار
الانجيل هو بمثابه مركز المعلومات الرئيسي
فيهم يعني نقدر نعتبره زي المكتبه كده
لانظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي واللي نقدر نشبهه
باعضاء نادي القصف الوحش الاسرائيلي ده
اللي بيحصل بحسب سام ان 90% على الاقل من
حجم البيانات وضحنا انواعها من شويه بيتم
جمعها في الانجيل وبعدها بيصنع لاهداف ثم
الانظمه الثانيه بتساعد على فحص وفلتره
الاهداف دي وتحديد المهم فيها من غير
المهم ومنظومه الذكاء الاصطناعي دي
المكونه من الاربع انظمه اللي نعرفهم
وغيرهم الانظمه الثانيه السريه بتمتد عبر
كل مجتمع الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي واجهزه
امن الاحتلال ولها وجود تقريبا في كل
مساحه هناك بتولد معلوم
الكلام ده اللي يوحي بان المنظومه دي شبه
الماتركس كده بياكد تصريحات رئيس اركان
جيش الاحتلال السابق افيف كوخافي في
مقابله ليه اخر يونيو اللي فات 2023 مع
ادعوت احرونوت واللي قال فيها ان جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي في
2023 مش بس مختلف عن نسخته في حرب اكتوبر
1973 او حرب لبنان
1982 لكن هو حاليا جيش مختلف جدا عن نسخته
من من 10 سنين بس في 2013 وان كل لواقف
الجيش عنده حاليا جهاز استخبارات متطور
شبه منظومه ذا ماتركس بيوفر معلومات
استخباراتيه في وقت حدوثها ريل تايم
انتلجنس لكن الكلمتين الاهم اللي قالهم هو
انه من بين جميع الثورات التكنولوجيه
المدنيه والعسكريه فغالبا الذكاء
الاصطناعي هيكون هو الثوره الاهم سواء
للافضل او للاسوا طبعا كوخافي كان المفروض
يقول هيكون الثوره الاسوا بالنسبه لاهلنا
في غزه الحقيقه ان كوخافي من وقت ما مسك
رئاسه الاركان في يناير 2019 وه عنده خطه
وسعه وطموحه جدا لتحديث جيش الاحتلال
والاعتماد على التكنولوجيا كبديل للقتال
البري والالتحام المباشر وبجانب
التكنولوجيا ف كوخافي كان مصر على ان
الجيش لازم يكون عنده قوه ردع اكبر تقدر
تهاجم باكبر قدر من القوه والعنف وبالتالي
تزيد فترات التهدئه الامنيه بين الح
الحروب علشان كده بعد ما مسك رئاسه
الاركان بكام شهر فعل خطه عسكريه شامله
اسمع ت نوفا واللي هي خطه بتقوم على زياده
القدرات الهجوميه لجيش الاحتلال ورفع
مستوى الانتاجيه والدقه ورغم ان الخطه
كانت محتاجه زياده في ميزانيه الدفاع
الاسرائيليه بحوالي 4 مليار شيكل او اكث
من مليار دولار الا ان كوخافي ما استناش
موافقه الحكومه ولا الموازنه زياده وانما
خد موافقه وزير الدفاع نفتالي بنات وبدا
تنفيذ الخطه بالفعل بالموارد اللي تحت
ايده وهنا هنيجي لواحده من المحطات المهمه
جدا في كلامنا النهارده وهي انشاء مديريه
الاستهداف احد المسؤولين الرئيسيين عن
الاعتداء المجرم اللي بنشوفه على غزه
حاليا ايه بقى قصه المديريه دي بالتزامن
مع تنفيذ خطه نوفا او يمكن كجزء منها وفي
نفس السنه 2020 تم انشاء مديريه الاستهداف
اللي بيشتغل فيها مئات الضباط والجنود
والتابعه للوحده 8200 واللي اللي بيصب
فيها تقريبا كل اللي بتعمله انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الخاصه بتحليل البيانات ووضع
الاهداف المديريه دي هي اللي تم من خلالها
تطوير نظام الانجيل مع انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الثانيه وتم تجربه شغلها بشكل
فعلي اثناء معركه سيف القدس في
2021 المعركه اللي اطلق عليها مسؤول
المخابرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه انها اول
حرب ذكاء اصطناعي في العالم لانه في
المعركه دي نظام الانجيل ولد 200 هدف من
ال 1500 هدف اللي تم ضربهم في القطاع في
11 يوم بس لحد وقف اطلاق النار في اول
تجربه حقيقيه ليه منظومه الذكاء الاصطناعي
الاسرائيليه وعلى راسها الانجيل اطورت جدا
في السنتين اللي فاتوا وبقت مصممه لانتاج
اهداف غزيره جدا في حاله حدوث حرب شامله
بين الكيان المحتل واي حد والدليل على ده
ان الاسرائيليين حاليا بيقصف غزه باجرام
كانها دوله كبيره بكم اهداف مذهل وده قصف
يصلح يكون تجربه عمليه بشعه للمنظومه دي
علشان الاسرائيليين يشوفوا اذا كانت هتنجح
لو دخلوا في حرب شامله مع ايران وحزب الله
مثلا ولا لا الحقيقه ان دوله الاحتلال
بتنتقم من سكان غزه بالفعل يعني لو بصينا
على تحقيق مجله بلس 97 ت موقع لوكال كول
هنلاقي استنباط واضح بان نظام الاي اي
الاسرائيلي الجهنمي ده بيستخدم لتوليد
اهداف طول الوقت علشان القوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تقدر تقصف غزه بمعدل هائل
وبلا انقطاع منظمه العفو الدوليه في
تحقيقها مع بدايه القصف في خمس مناطق
مختلفه في غزه ما لقتش اي دليل على وجود
مقاتلين او اهداف عسكريه في كل منطقه وقت
الهجمات يعني الهجمات كانت كلها على
مدنيين بس ولقت ان جيش الاحتلال ما اخدش
اي احتياطات لحمايه المدنيين قبل القصف
وفي بعض الحالات ما حذرو سكان المناطق دي
اطلاقا وفي حالات ثانيه بعتوا تحذيرات غير
كافيه وقالت المنظمه في تحقيقها انها لقت
ادله دماغه بتشير لوجود جرائم حرب في حمله
القصف الاسرائيليه سام ايفانز باحث مركز
الروس الامني شدد في كلامه مع الاناضول
على انه مهم جدا نفهم ان ضباط الاستخبارات
والمحللين الاسرائيليين بيشاركوا في
عمليات تحديد الاهداف ونقلها لقوات
الاحتلال في جميع الاوقات علشان كده عدد
قتلى غزه الرهيب ده بيرجع بحس بساام
لكيفيه استخدام اسرائيل للتكنولوجيا اللي
معاها بالنسبه لسام فالذكاء الاصطناعي هو
مجرد اداه بتقدم التوصيات والبشر هم اللي
بياخدوا القرار علشان كده هو شايف اننا
مهم نميز ما بين دور الذكاء الاصطناعي في
الحرب دي وهو دور احنا لسه مش عارفين ما
يكفي عنه وبين الطريقه اللي بيدير بها
الاسرائيليين الحرب ودي حاجه مختلفه طبعا
الكلام ده مظبوط وواضح جدا ان في توجه عند
القيادات السياسيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
بعد فشلهم المذري في 7 اكتوبر وعلى راسهم
رئيس الوزراء المترنح والمتهاون نتنياهو
باستهداف اكبر قدر ممكن من الفلسطينيين
وانزال سياسات عقاب جماعي بلا رحمه على
رؤوسهم جميعا وده معناه بالضروره انه
هيكون في عدم مراجعه من العاملين في
مديريه الاستهداف الاسرائيليه للاهداف
اللي بيحددها الذكاء الاصطناعي وهين قلو
بشكل سريع وبلا تدقيق كبير لقوات الاحتلال
اللي حولت القطاع لبحر واسع من الدماء
الدليل على ده هو عدد شهداء غزه و مصابيه
ومفقودين تحت الانقاض واللي قارب على
100000 فلسطيني وحجم الدمار الواسع اللي
وصل لان كل مبنى من ثلاث مباني في غزه
تعرض للتدمير او لضرر جانبي جراء القصف
ودي نسبه وصل لها تحليل مستقل اجرا كوري
شير من مركز الدراسات العليا في جامعه
مدينه نيويورك وجامو فاندن هوك من جامعه
ولايه اوريجون ودليل ثاني كمان هنلاقيه في
المعلومه اللي اكدها عدد كبير من المصادر
الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه الاسرائيليه اللي
اتكلمت مع مجله بلس 97 ت موقع لوكال كول
بشرط عدم الكشف عن هويتها وعت ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عنده ملفات لمعظم الاهداف
المحتمله في غزه وان الملفات دي فيها عدد
المدنيين المحتمل سقوطهم ضحايا في اي هجوم
على اي هدف واكدت المصادر دي ان العدد
معروف مسبقا لوحدات استخبارات الجيش واللي
بتكون عارفه برده قبل وقت قصير من تنفيذ
الهجوم العدد التقريبي للمدنيين اللي اكيد
هيتم قتلهم في القصف الجوي او المدفعي
وبجانب جرايم الحرب الاسرائيليه
والاستهداف المتعمد للمدنيين بدافع
الانتقام ففي مشكله ثانيه كبيره في منظومه
الاي اي دي وهي انها هتدي اي جهه عسكريه
القدره الكامله على التنصل من تبعات
المذابح اللي هترت كبها يعني لو حبينا
نحاسب حد ونقضي من جهه القانون الدولي على
جرايم الحرب دي والدماء دي كلها نحاسب مين
المحللين اللي قبلوا توصيات منظومه الذكاء
الاصطناعي ولا المبرمجين اللي صنعوا
النظام الاول ولا ضباط المخابرات اللي
جمعوا البيانات اللي غزت شبكه الاي اي دي
ولا القيادات اللي وجهت كل اللي شغالين
دول بانهم يعملوا ما بدلهم وماحدش هيراجع
وراهم في الختام وعلشان ما اطولش على
حضراتكم ندعو الله السلامه لاهلنا في غزه
والرحمه للشهداء والشفاء للمصابين احنا
معاكم وجنبكم دايما وهنستخدم
الكيان الصهيوني للعالم وبدعوى استمرار في
المقاطعه بغض النظر عن تاثيرها على
الشركات الداعمه للكيان الصهيوني لكن يكفي
بس اننا نقدر نبص لنفسنا في المرايه لان
المقاطعه زي ما وضحنا مرارا قبل كده هي
سلوك اخلاقي في المقام الاول بعدها يجي اي
حاجه لازم دي تكون نقطه الانطلاق بتاعتنا
في اي شيء متعلق بنصره اخواننا فلسطين انه
التزام اخلاقي بغض النظر عن النتائج
هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه تلا فيت
عشان لو انت مستورد وحابب تتعامل معاهم
وتستورد من خلالهم المنتجات دي ويا ريت
تعرفوني في التعليقات ايه اللي مستنيينه
مننا في الموسم الجديد في 2024 ان شاء
الله وايه التطويرات اللي منتظرينها في
البرنامج ومحتواه
[موسيقى]
سلام
ا